[Music]
Thank You Clark he understands my my
weaknesses hi as Clark said I first got
here in the in the fall of 1925 as a
freshman an incredibly long time ago it
seems like to me I will therefore talk
about I suppose those five years or so
which follow the years that Hoyt huttle
has just talked about I came here from
my hometown of West Hoboken New Jersey a
raucous suburb of New York City with a
number of drinking established once I
suppose and a town about which my
associates my then associates and I like
to refer to as the Athens of America a
slight exaggeration of the circumstances
it it certainly differed from Boston
Boston seemed to me to be a backward
community with of course none of its
present vitality it was a place for
example where when I first went to
restaurants to eat why I found that they
were often called sparse sparse indeed
Moxie was a then reasonably strong
competitor
of coca-cola remarkable the the
clam chowder was in fact made with milk
as it still is instead of tomatoes and
and a lot of people talked funny like
Ted Kennedy does today I really I really
thought that I had come to the end of
the civilized world here I thought that
permafrost and Labrador started just a
few miles north of Cambridge the
Institute too was a very different place
and let me just tell you that as far as
I can remember it had about 10% of its
present floor area it comprised the
buildings of let's say one through five
as they exist at the present time plus
seven plus ten of course Plus Walker
Memorial Plus Rogers across the river
and some wooden shacks out back the the
corridors were thronged of course with
students relatively hairless masculine
students dressed if you please in in in
suits coats vests ties and so on very
few women it seemed to me a rather
monastic place circumstance perhaps
which we we all regretted at any rate
there was practically no landscaping the
space between and a good many of you
will remember between buildings two and
four and Waka memorial that space was
covered with coarse gravel remember as
was the main the main court again coarse
gravel
there was no art to speak of no
Levinson's no Calder's no Picasso
I've rather grown to like those
creations with the passage of time that
is and and I think that it's an
indication of the way an engineer can
grow that even that engineer who I know
particularly felt strongly about those
sculptures who who said that they made
him think of the droppings of b-29s
flying overhead unfairly he has changed
his tune he now he now finds them
acceptable at any rate it's an
indication that the engineer is capable
of aesthetic growth that seems like to
me now I came to the Institute for the
same reasons I guess that a good many of
my classmates did first of all I liked
to carry out chemical experiments at
home successfully without blowing off
any fingers I enjoyed of course machines
as my classmates did and of course I was
attracted by the enormous reputation of
the Institute of way of this department
was generally recognized that the
chemical industry was on the verge of
explosive growth and and that the
Institute would have a large hand in in
providing the men to carry forward that
development I think the man who was of
course primarily responsible for that
for that reputation was wk Lewis a man
who was in and out of of the department
headship he didn't particularly like the
job but nevertheless he imposed at that
time it seemed to us his standards on
the department it seems to me that he
had the four attributes that are
critical to academic leadership
first of all he had a reputation he had
a record of accomplishment second he
knew way he was going to go where he
wanted the profession to go third he he
certainly he certainly wanted to he
certainly wanted to let me see I had a
third one here somewhere it must be the
early the early hour that that gets me
down he he certainly surrounded himself
with with with an extremely capable
staff and fourthly of course he was a
communicator as we all know incidentally
I I i rather stumbled over those they
make me think however of what we are
looking for in our national leadership
at the present time God knows the
and they the first
let me tell you that as far as they as
the first one was concerned and let me
see if I can remember them in order but
the first one was the issue of his
record as successful record he did as
far as we know it was in collaboration
with Arthur T little that the unit ops
concepts were formulated but but it
seems to me WK did something more he he
draped those concepts was that sort of a
mathematical formulation which is
critical to design to plant design
second on the issue of of what he
proposed to do he recognized very
clearly as has been so nicely brought
out and in the previous talks professor
Scriven and and Professor Hottel
that our thermodynamics of course were
inadequate at the time at least for
chemical engineering we urgently needed
thermodynamics again he recognized it
seems to me that the rate processes
especially with respect to a mass
transfer had not gotten a proper amount
of attention and finally in his favorite
field of industrial chemistry he he
recognized that there was a new
developing field on the verge of
bursting onto the industrial scene
polymers and again colloid chemistry he
he pioneered in all those fields I I
still remember that whilst I was an
undergraduate here why the he wk had
instituted an experimental subject
called chemical thermodynamics and it
was one that was attended that subject
by a few c-like graduate students a good
many of the staff attended the noises
that came out of the classroom
through those closed doors I remember as
I went by I were fantastic it was a
disputatious period of time at any rate
so much for for the second requirement
he he knew where he wanted to go third
he attracted a surprisingly capable
group of associates I don't think an
equal assemblage of of stars has existed
since in the profession let me very
briefly go through maybe a few of them I
won't show you pictures it takes too
much time and you probably remember them
anyway the first alphabetically doing it
that way would be of course at Gilliland
who was before I first met him I was
told that this was a this was a country
boy from the Middle West well let me
tell you what when I got into my first
technical session with Ed Gilliland I
was dazzled and astonished in my long
life I have met a great many people even
Nobel laureates I would say that Edie
comes close to heading that list in
terms of capacity he had another quality
which I think perhaps is unusual in
engineers although I don't mean to run
down my profession but he had a quality
of sweetness which is which was a very
nice thing to see he was a nice guy in
addition to everything else second one
McAdams he was a workaholic who who
certainly liked to verbalize his
thinking he had talked all the time and
and recited his thoughts and he liked to
have his assistant standing by listening
and when
Cerie making inputs it was a it was an
arduous business but I must hasten to
say very educational Mac loved parties
and he loved to sing accompanying
himself of course on a guitar I think he
would have made a good stand-in for some
for one of the Peter Paul and Mary group
except for the circumstance of their
politics he would have had no sympathy I
think they're the third person I think
let me see if I've got this straight
sure what I think would be next that
suave Canadian who that pioneer in mass
transfer he was a man of many talents
ranging from oil painting to well
mountain climbing if you can call that a
talent it may be madness he was
remarkable it seems to me because he
kept the neatest desk that I think I
have ever seen at the Institute he had
one other accomplishment unusual in an
academic I think he always got things
done ahead of time
remarkable next next
Harold Weber how about jolly engineer
again capable I think I think he I think
he was just as interested in electronics
in those days as he was in chemical
engineering as a matter of fact one of
his early patents probably anticipates
the transistor if I have gotten the
story straight from people who should
know Whitman a charmer a born diplomat
brought in by WK Lewis
to run the department he's brought back
he'd been in the department for a while
went industry came back he performed
beautifully during the war of course in
the war production board later in the
State Department he needed all his
diplomacy at times to run his what shall
I say his stable of academics who did
not likely take to too much direction at
any rate therefore that was his that was
his his his his next accomplishment he
could therefore managed to attract
outstanding associates now then I
suppose the next quality is his his
capacity to communicate how am i doing i
stopped very soon his capacity to
communicate remarkable he could put
things very very simply indeed he his
classes well almost always as you have
heard put on a discussion basis he
proceeded through a really brilliantly
formulated series of questions which
developed the points that he wanted to
develop beautifully we all of us thought
that he probably was a direct descendant
of Socrates and he done it so what now
then those are the those are the
qualities it seems that wk Lewis had I'd
like to illustrate the his his abilities
to communicate his quick witnesses
witness by a couple of anecdotes there
isn't time perhaps I'll attempt only one
I he w K Louis and I in the
last I think in the later decades of his
of his life orphan took walks together
around the basin here weed after lunch
at Walker let's say we would start out
across the Longfellow bridge then down
along the Esplanade and back over
Harvard bridge proceeding always at high
speed dock talking practically all the
time usually haranguing me on some issue
or another at any rate I remember very
well on one occasion the that we we were
walking along behind the Emerson dorms
and as we came up there I noticed that
there was a group of girls standing
there looking at us as we proceeded at
high speed giggling and pointing a young
girl separated from that group and came
up for us I think both dark and I
suspected that this might be an
initiation stunt at any rate she she
approached us and looked at dock ran
along practically keeping up with us and
said to him do you think that sex and
birth control
are here to stay he looked after for a
moment interrupted his discussion of the
phosphorus chlorides as I remember it
which we were developing and said
without hesitation that question has no
relevance to a man of my age and then
proceeded to local law both of us
leaving the girl leaving the girl
standing the
find looking after us well there are the
stories of dark are endless and they're
great
he was the remarkable person I should I
should finish it's I think it's great
that you've all come you know we we've
had we've all of us had a great time
here at the Institute we enjoy it
enormous Lee we love the place we've
glad we're glad that you've returned
thank you very much
[Applause]
apparently I have forgotten one issue
that I did want to bring up and this is
a characteristic of an aging mind I have
great difficulty in remembering things I
was going to tell you that that
Professor Hottel I hope he will forgive
me but he of course I guess I told you
that he is in a class with Gilliland but
he is somewhat forgetful from time to
time and I hope he will forgive me if I
mentioned the fact that
characteristically for example he did on
one occasion travel to a professional
meeting in Providence by automobile then
returned after a very arduous day by
train that evening leaving our
we now have a break in view of our tight
schedule I asked you to be back in your
seats
if at all possible in 20 minutes which
would be five minutes to 11:00 at this
stage we shift gears and we go from the
present to the future our next speaker
is Jim Wei who will be giving us some
perspectives on future directions in
chemical engineering as you know the
faculty just returned from a two-day
meeting that was held prior to the
convocation in which we assessed the
present status and future directions of
chemical engineering in addition Jim Wei
served on as vice chairman of a National
Academy of Sciences committee to look
into the same topic and therefore is
uniquely qualified to give us his
perspective on where we'll be going Jim
happy birthday
I want to tell you that this is not only
the centennial of the Department of
Chemical Engineering founded in 1888
but in 1908 six people founded the
American Institute of chemical engineers
including own Arthur D little and
William H Walker so this is also the
80th birthday of AIChE so this is a
double birthday and I have the unique
privilege of being head of the
department and president of the ICC at
the same time so let's say happy
birthday I also want to say that the
registration showed that we have one
member of the class of 1923 here
ragnar nice but there is a late
registrant also here today Dunbar
Shanklin who likes very much to get
together with him I suspect they might
not have met for 55 years with Ragnar
where are you would you raise your arm
Ragnar is here where is Dunbar
[Applause]
I'm sure you'll have a great reunion
yeah you there are a number of talks
before about great achievements that we
have achieved in the last century but we
also heard from the Provost about crisis
coming and storm clouds on the horizon
now Paul Gray appointed a commission to
study productivity and competition and
we start looking into the question about
how the various industries are doing and
one the question is why America is no
longer making things that the rest of
the world want to buy now we made the
study and we found that the good news is
that the chemical industry is one of the
two most successful American industries
today they are maintaining a healthy
world competition in earning a surplus
of eleven billion dollars of export /
import this year now I am tempted to say
that this is because the chemical
industry is managed by chemical
engineers they have superior brains
excellent education and good looks
that we do believe that the chemical
industry has what we call an innovative
culture at the top management of these
industries they are usually chemical
engineers who love to make things well
and they're committed to the long-range
view and cutting-edge technologies as
the competitive tool in the world
now we educators have to try to play a
role in maintaining this innovative
culture four years ago a group of
chemical engineers got together to begin
a study on chemical engineering
frontiers research needs and
opportunities and the DES sponsorship of
the National Academies I've been talking
to the students for quite some time now
about the frontiers what it is how to
get there and how to stay on top so the
student chapter of the AIChE put
together a t-shirt that looks like this
and it says MIT AIChE frontiers and
chemical engineering with logos on
biotechnology microelectronics
computer-aided engineering and so forth
I heard there are still a few left in
the stock if you feel you cannot leave
Cambridge without one you should talk to
the student chapter AIChE leaders and
see what they can do for you now this
committee has produced a report last
year and I brought you a copy of the
report to show you and it is very
handsomely done and it is required
reading for all chemical engineers who
seriously want to know where the future
is
we have also produced
and a bridge version written in simpler
language was pretty pictures they are
intended for high school students and
for your boss sir congressman who be
sure they get hold a copy and present it
to them and tell them there's a lot of
future there now the good news in these
reports tells you that there are many
splendid opportunities for chemical
engineers in the next century there are
many of them are due to new science
developments which open up technologies
that have unprecedented power to improve
our lives in areas such as biotechnology
microelectronics and advanced materials
we the chemical engineers have the
concepts and tools to help develop these
industries second many of the
traditional industries especially in
energy and basing materials affected by
the globalization of manufacturing and
technology and threatens to move
offshore but there are many
opportunities for us chemical engineers
to use good science and good engineering
to make them low cost produces and keep
them here and that's another opportunity
the third one is that the public has
much greater expectations now from us on
Community Health and Safety and on
Environmental Protection and we should
show the world that we are the solutions
and not the problems and we should
declare ourselves to be the cradle and
grave guardians of toxic substances from
the generation transportation use and
final disposal these are the good news
but now how do we get there from here do
we already possess
all the tools and concepts we need as
Kant mentioned that for the last two
days we have invited 35 leading
educators and researchers for symposium
on the intellectual foundations of
chemical engineering we know want to
know how do we get there from here let
me tell you some of the general
consensus that we have arrived that we
already have many of the required
concepts and tools in our curriculum to
equip our students to be effective we
are good at working at things at the
molecular scale as some of the speakers
last two days told us that we are now
moving from an era of manufacturing of
electronic things mechanical steps such
as soldering wires blowing glass to an
era of molecular or chemical fabrication
steps like chemical vapour deposition
this is also happening in the ceramic
and a polymer area and we feel that we
have unique contributions because
chemical manufacturing is becoming
important however we really don't have
all the tools we need yet to learn these
new industries to get into biotechnology
we need to learn biochemistry and
genetics and we need to learn about
polymer chemistry solid-state chemistry
many many subjects that are not in our
curriculum and we need to forge
multidisciplinary teams because we
cannot do it alone we need partners and
we have to learn how to work with
harness
and we also need to develop a lot of new
engineering sciences and techniques
computer programs analytical procedures
models to solve these very difficult and
complex problems we are very good at
solving problems involving small simple
molecules in the past now we got a deal
with complex difficult how to
characterize substances and we have to
do that well there's a lot of
implications from these conferences and
there is a big implication on the
educational side that I'd like to talk
about for a moment we need to broaden
the line of our undergraduate students
they are used to studying the science
subjects the engineering science
subjects we need to help them to
integrate all these together into a set
of courses which to start off from
considerations in the marketplace who
needs these products what kind of
specifications they should have and how
do we design them how do we put a
process together and what are the
downstream consequences of these
processes would it pollute the air air
and these are set of innovative courses
which we call the ice courses or the
integrated chemical engineering courses
they'll be described next by professors
Evans Sean and Merrill now there is an
increasing demand that we put more and
more material in our curriculum people
who said how can you turn our chemical
engineer who doesn't know quantum
mechanics what about molecular biology
and biochemistry surely they must know
at least two computer languages and to
be effective in a global economy how can
they leave without learning foreign
languages and foreign cultures and
surely they cannot leave without
understanding
environment and social concerns and of
course what about ethics very important
topics all of them but you know that an
MIT education is like drinking from a
firehose you have all heard that when
you came as a freshman and now is this
time to increase the pressure on the
fire hose now there are a number of
things that we are wrestling with and we
keep on finding ourselves coming back
and back to the question how do you make
the put more material in and still get
through in four years and the students
still should have time to watch the Red
Sox game to drink beer and the
dormitories and to make friendships and
grow as individuals I think that it is
time for us to put aside the pretense
that we can really turn our a
professional engineer in a four year of
college the truth is that we have never
done that engineering education has
always been a partnership between
universities and industry the
universities teach them the fundamentals
and the graduates enter industry to work
they work as apprentices under the
watchful eyes of senior engineers who
can teach them the ropes and watch over
for their mistakes for a number of years
before they can really do independent
engineering work this is really no
different from medical education where
the internship and residency are done in
hospitals and clinics and we have our
students doing them in the industries of
course this is the concept of the
practice school which of John Deutsche
mention is forming a model of education
in MIT now it is
time for us to recognize that the
four-year bachelor's degree is a general
preparation for a number of exciting
careers what do I mean if you take a
four-year bachelor's degree it gives you
a very good general preparation you can
go to work for industry and get on a job
training to do a number of very very
exciting things and for many of the less
technically demanding careers they will
also prepare them for professional
schools of business and medicine and law
and but if you want to do a technical a
very demanding function such as
engineering design and development it's
very important to take advanced courses
and to get a master's degree because a
bachelor's degree just won't be enough
for the more demanding subjects and to
be effective in the new high-tech areas
you will need courses in the new
sciences in the biochemistry and the
polymers in the microelectronics and of
course we know to do teaching and
research we need a doctor's degree now
this is all very well you're saying what
about accreditation what would the
president of AIChE say and well what
abet say now the answer may well be that
we should design a four-year bachelor's
degree to be a more broadening
experience the students who stopped at
for years would have a good general
preparation but we really ought to what
I would call practice truth in labeling
we should shift the focus of
accreditation to the master's degree now
we are beginning to really put enough
subjects together and experience
together to train a professional student
for the future
da Lewis used to tell us that chemical
engineer can do anything and we
certainly agree with him with him
staring down at us we had to agree and
of course we know that he was right not
only we are all born with superior
intelligence and good looks we also have
a splendid education and the most
important thing is that we do our
homework and we keep on doing our
homework up till we graduate from
college we keep up with the world we
keep educating ourselves and we keep
preparing ourselves for the future I
want to say that my fellow chemical
engineers the next century would be even
more glorious than the first century
thank you
[Applause]